ما كان يمكن أن يقال عن
رفض الاشتراك في Netflix لـ
تبقي حسد السينما مهما كنت
فكر في الأفلام التي ستصدر في 6 سنوات
الحد الأدنى من الاهتمام سنذهب إليه
جعل سمع مباشرة صرخ إلى
30 عاما من عمري صعبة للغاية
[موسيقى]
كلما أردنا الذهاب إلى السينما أكثر
ها نحن نحتاج أيضًا إلى مساحة
الكبار أيضًا للصغار أيضًا
وهذا أيضًا ما سيحتاج إلى القليل
قليلا قليلا من الأدب المنظم
مبلغ العطاء كابيلا الأمريكية
بواسطة alpha manas german film outsiders 4
إلى الشهود ادعى جيمس بوند
البكتيريا التي تنتظر البطء
أحبه مثل السعال البريطاني
الثلث الأول تقريبا
تأكيد
الأمريكيون يشيرون
إعادة فتح دور السينما الخاصة بهم
لتكون قادرة على تطأ قدماه في
المناجم الأمريكية التي يوجد بها اللهب
فرنسا هناك سارة لا تفوت
فيلم كاميلوت ميدالية السقف ثم
برونزية 17 توني شارب وحولها
الأسماء المحلية
الرياضة راي ليما
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]